welcome to this video playing my way
again and we probably get the Scotch
Jack as usual he always plays not this
time he has changed his mind it did last
night f5 okay on here there is g6 or the
caption I think g6 is what I play yeah I
need to attend to g7 I cannot ignore it
this way he has taken unknown on b6
which is a slight improvement for me
giving black and somewhat increased play
on the dark squares let's see maybe I
can quickly get an f5 night age five and
then f5 my looks very shaky em yeah
maybe it is still irritating if I give
the check you can go G 3m after the
capture can play Queen f2 I have queen
age six though looks very that's all
your risk iam okay still I feel tempted
takes Queen after Queen age 6 s
something that I can play
maybe it's a maybe it's too risky thing
but still tempted Queen takes Queen III
of course hgi take the rook but there is
95 those kind of moves that maybe maybe
will be problematic okay but that some
it's interesting yeah what should you do
is giving up the exchange that's clearly
compensation for white that's absolutely
clear okay I play something like 95
maybe attacking here now it could be
just a big time loss maybe go back pin
and pin de three night for a moment yeah
how do I am how do I defend him should G
to cook h1 is probably coming and one
lever should play something like f5
maybe o Queen g7 no Queen g7 then maybe
a five okay let's try to get some
counter play
I take maybe take simply taking and then
Bishop f5 if possible no and now no
Bishop f5 is pretty pointless um you
should be six rook e8 rook to e8 the a
file is not really giving me any any
special plane yeah I don't know a
computer probably would defend this
without any any big problem but he has
this 95 and look at pretty good pieces
yeah def five maybe
there's some way to get a direct
counterplay of b5 or anything probably
not young fine i can i can still move
the better away yeah maybe this I don't
I don't know it's it's difficult f5 i
don't know if i go back here he's got
bishop the bishop checker at least maybe
I should go here f6 I have queen age six
and probably I have 95 or queen e 5 as
the defense of idea yeah look h 1 i've
got queen gt5
not sure how problematic this is I feel
that the g 585 square should be good
defensive posts you can play Queen age
too of course but I thought age six
would be sufficient at least now I have
to play this problem you can now take on
age six but how good is that I can go
nitey five at the end
and it's just a ticking on c7 yeah
taking taking here I don't know maybe
this is easier Knight takes rook e4 as
simple and Bishop takes King g7 looks
fairly safe the I can't I can take this
was my idea do I need to take though I
can go to III also and g 5 10 why not I
can take h6 a large e5 check ah what a
tactic why not just take it for and it's
basically over tweenage success is
winning for right now I could just take
you form rookie for Luke f6 and white is
just material down for nothing and it's
not seeing this on what just made really
Queen age 6 is made Queen h6 Queenie 695
check King age aite group G rook h6 mate
yeah maybe it's not the type of person
who wants to be annoying i believe he is
probably really not seeing it at least
not yet wow this was very lucky punk
okay come on let's get rid of this this
is bloody night okay my money crook here
maybe I am come on I need I need more
pieces him I cannot play h5 here cannot
take with the Queen does he threatened
to take here maybe check I didn't see
that all while what a game oh Jesus it's
unbelievable I really I don't know if
you don't play a warm-up game at
sometimes it's really not good but even
with warm up games or sometimes really
play like a [ __ ] this is one of those
games and I cannot defend this
unbeliever
black resigns ah what a game yeah I mean
okay I probably deserve to lose I mean
it's clear that he had like is probably
just winning but yeah of course he could
have one very easily he MK and this here
I just need to take take take take and
it's gone this is two pawns and I get
the knight to e5 why it has absolutely
nothing here just two points for nothing
it's a very easy win in fact and this is
just check made which I overlooked it's
pretty easy jack checkmate mate play
this now again I'm totally winning night
before is the easiest it's minus 7 I
didn't see that at all because I wanted
to get rid of this this dangerous serve
this dangerous piece and this is not so
clear this is not so clear some tricky
to play yeah only have a slight
advantage which I'm spoiling with with
this of course Luke Luke age 16 but the
problem was my original intention was to
do this of course which can look h5
simply refutes yeah i was still totally
irritated by the things that happened
before and with one minute spent he
didn't see between aged 60 remarkable
and and here where this is this is just
winning for nothing am this is the
problem Queen d3 check and of course all
white pieces on are badly coordinated
okay the first game of the session hmm
it's really good okay thanks for
watching